okay what is Spike Lee AOC Jesse
Smollett in ill-mannered teens tell us
about modern-day liberalism answer a
heck of a lot now let's start with Spike
Lee the iconic director is worth
millions so he's made millions it's done
really well over 30 years though he was
nominated no fewer than five times for
an Academy Award
but until last night he had never won an
Oscar but he took home the award for
adapting the screenplay for his movie
black clansmen rather than showing
humility and gratitude he spiked the
moment with a tiresome political
diatribe the 2020 presidential election
is around the corner there's all Bova
lines
let's all be in the right side of
history mate the rope might make the
moral choice between love versus hate
let's do the right thing number one lane
that after all these years he couldn't
memorize his lines number two lame that
he couldn't accept the honor without
gratuitous cursing which you couldn't
even hear because the Oscars had to
believe him
number three disagreeing with your
political vision spike doesn't make you
a moral or a bad person now like I've
said before liberals are angry sometimes
even when they should be happy and most
are off the charts intolerant and
judgmental of people who don't think
like they do and Lee just like in his
latest film suffers from kind of a
deficit of both subtlety and grace
perhaps not surprisingly the president
couldn't resist lobbing a post Oscars
response tweeting be nice if Spike Lee
could read his notes or better yet not
have to use notes at all when doing his
racist hit on your president who's done
more for african-americans criminal
justice reform lowest unemployment in
years in history tax cuts etc than
almost any other Prez well beyond
politics which shouldn't have been a
part of Hollywood's big night anyway
Spike Lee's performance lacks some grace
I think to regular people he just came
across as kind of bratty rude
self-absorbed an egotist masquerading
though as a brilliant social justice
warrior the old Spike Lee gotta go back
like 30 35 years was that least kind of
cutting edge and I have a question
should we judge him for some of his old
movie lines like this one when
describing a girl he had relations with
what about solo dog what do you want to
know I thought she was a freak you know
rinky-dinky you asked why I can see the
sear it looked like a [ __ ] I'm not
crazy
well but this craziness goes way beyond
Spike Lee it's the same arrogant
self-important thinking that propelled
Empire star jussie Smollett in the
believing he could stage an anti manga
hoax and then conclude that hit emerge
as a hero making a scene and casting
yourself as the wounded martyr is what
these elites do best you see when you're
on the right side of history it's your
duty to start a national conversation
and inject yourself into the middle of
it facts
they're irrelevant kind of passe as the
famed political philosopher Alexandria
Castillo Cortez once observed there's a
lot of people more concerned about being
precisely factually and semantically
correct than about being morally right
well like most of today's social justice
warriors AOC truly believes she is
always morally right and that notion
entitles her to be one of the leaders of
not the me to movement but the mimimi
movement she's been on the job for
exactly two months and you would swear
her green New Deal is a second
Declaration of Independence I just
introduced green you deal two weeks ago
and it's creating all of this
conversation why because no one else has
even tried so people are like oh it's
unrealistic
oh it's vague oh it doesn't address this
little minut thing and I'm like you try
you do it
cuz you're not cuz you're not so until
you do it I'm the boss
I know you didn't I mean she's like 25
29 years old and she's like the boss of
Congress and it's like totally it must
be nice but what she lacks in experience
she's excited and it's kind of good
she's in there in the mix she likes kind
of expected to but she makes up for all
of it and ego and confidence got to give
her that but her demands they seem
familiar I once the world I want the
whole world I want to lock it all up in
my pockets my chocolates give it to me
[Music]
well Acosta cordoes is allergy to
protocol combined with her I want it now
mentality is the byproduct of the
byproduct of the everyone gets a trophy
era in which she was raised where
coddled kids grow up to be entitled
adults who needs manners and decorum
when you've just been rewarded for
speaking your truth you always have to
hate your hate your chest when you say
speaking your truth whatever and
whatever you want when adults indulge
youngsters we get shallow thinkers and
by the way this entire notion of
speaking your truth is goofy because it
presupposes that there really is no
objective truth your truth isn't
necessarily the truth and it's probably
just your opinion and you're entitled to
have it but until you've lived fallen
and failed it's probably fairly
uninformed even if it's entertaining and
highly energetic you're entitled to
speak all you'd like of course First
Amendment everybody is entitled an
opinion but Noah's is obligated to
listen to you and whether you're an
overrated director a minor TV actor or
Vogue's congressional it girl none of it
matters and that goes by the way for
rude middle school and high school
students who are coached to get in the
face of adults on Capitol Hill and just
like talk to them like they're their
contemporaries their Instagram buddies
what am I talking about well on Friday
Senator Dianne Feinstein was confronted
by a group of AOC minimis lobbying for
the green New Deal natch in her office
check out this exchange scientists have
said that we have 12 years to turn this
around well it's not going to get turned
around
ten years what we can do in ten years
the faces of the people who are going to
be living with you I've been doing this
for thirty years I know what I'm doing
you come in here and you say it has to
be my way or the highway I don't respond
to that I know what I'm doing so you
know maybe people should listen a little
bit where are the people who voted you
you're supposed to listen to us that's
your how old are you I'm 16 I didn't
vote for me well this may have been
Feinstein's finest hour
well she was forced to deal with
immature militant activists that her
party is churning out by the thousands
activists who usually confront and then
try to embarrass Republicans again the
blame isn't with the kids their students
it's with their parents or is that their
teacher let's face it if there was no
cell phones recording every word
how many would even be there so many
people today they crave attention they
want to have their moment I understand
and Spike Lee and AOC and these activist
tots should take note making a scene and
posting it on social may feel good but
it's no substitute for accomplishment or
hard work whether you're a liberal or
conservative or something in between
just try listening to the opposing view
then sharpening your arguments no matter
how much you virtue signal harassing
people isn't a talent it's just lazy and
in the end lazy is just boring and it
rarely wins and that's the angle